hey everybody is Charlie hopefully
you've had a chance to see the Black
Panther movie this is gonna be my video
for why some key moments during the
Black Panther movie and during
spider-man and his movies set them up to
be Marvel's most important Avengers
characters going into phase four so if
you're finding me for the first time
obviously there's gonna be so much
Avengers level stuff dropping in the
next month be sure to subscribe to get
everything I'm also doing an Infinity
Gauntlet giveaway that I'll talk about
at the end of the video too there's
always a lot of questions about regime
changes actors coming to the ends of
their contracts even if a lot of the
phase 1 Avengers stick around and I
think they will Kevin Feige has already
started to change the way that they put
their movies together so whereas during
phase 1 phase 2 even part of phase 3 you
would have a single character get their
solo movie they do an origin story they
do a couple sequels pretty standard fare
for movies but when you're trying to do
a big Avengers level universe where they
all crossover and team up every couple
of movies you just need to have a couple
of people who are so popular that
audiences can easily identify with them
and you can use them to market your
giant universe and Marvel got really
lucky during phase 1 when Ironman blew
up so Robert Downey jr. an Iron Man the
character sort of became the foundation
for the Avengers universe along came
Captain America and Thor not quite as
popular from box-office stand points as
Robert Downey jr. 'he's character so now
that they're all coming to the ends of
their contracts who is going to be the
new foundation for this phase 4 phase 5
whatever going forward the next 10 years
of Marvel movies there's this really
funny game of Thrones quote from season
5 where Varys is trying to convince
Tyrion to join the Targaryen restoration
and he says a monarch who can intimidate
the High Lords inspire the people a
ruler loved by millions with a powerful
army in the right family name a monarch
who can intimidate the High Lords and
inspire the people a ruler loved by
millions with a powerful army and the
right family name good luck finding him
so in that context he was talking about
Daenerys Targaryen with the right family
name that the people loved with a giant
army at her back
so after this weekend there shouldn't be
any question about who that is in the
Marvel
universe that's black panther he was
groomed to be a leader his entire life
so regardless of whether Robert Downey
jr. stays or he goes he takes a more
background role you need somebody that
can sit in that leaders chair and bring
the Avengers together whenever it comes
time for the fifth Avengers film and
that just reads like Black Panther he
has the most powerful army the most
advanced nation on the planet it is a
character that has one foot in the
magical realm because of their
connection to the Panther goddess the
way that they travel between planes of
existence the realm of the dead they
coat the Dajjal eeeh and the comic books
they just call it the spirit realm in
the movies and he has one foot in the
technological realm so he's one of those
characters that you can just put into
any kind of story and they haven't
introduced Captain Marvel yet but his
connection with her in the comics
through the ultimate steam is also the
route to Black Panther cosmic stories
you can send him into outer space and it
still totally works but at the other end
of that spectrum the reason why
spider-man is also one of the most
important characters in franchises to
the future of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe is is because he's our man's
heir apparent within the Marvel
Cinematic Universe like Iron Man is
shepherding him in on his way to
becoming a full-blown Avenger he's still
a teenager so he still makes lots of
mistakes but he's the point-of-view
character that's discovering everything
for the first time oh my god
this is so amazing the character himself
in real life is also one of the most
popular comic book characters in the
history of the world from a box office
from a revenue standpoint his
merchandise so he's somebody that you
can actually build a cinematic universe
around because he's so popular with
audiences look whatever the spider-man
story is people will go out and droves
to see it obviously you have to make a
good movie or else people will stop
going to see them but the two key things
like I said that you need you need to
have the right character that's written
to be a leader or could potentially
become a leader in spider-man's case
like you believed that he could
eventually lead the Avengers someday
given enough time it in real life the
characters have to have a big enough
international appeal that audiences will
just buy tickets for every member of
their family to go see it a couple
different times so they can become
billion-dollar franchises here's what we
need to get into Black Panther details
so just careful for spoilers if you have
not seen the movie
wait just a second so during that
post-credit scene you learn about the
outreach centers that he is creating all
over the world in big centers some of
those locations in addition to Oakland
are Hong Kong London in New York City
why do those locations sound familiar
those are the same locations is dr.
Strange's sanctums and he's sort of the
mystical protector of the earth black
panther is a little more physical
although he has one foot in the mystical
realm so it'd actually be pretty easy to
cross him over with the Doctor Strange
story but it tells you that Black
Panther can go anywhere around the world
he has spies informants people in every
big Marvel location that you would go to
so the movie embeds him everywhere there
was even a special featurette they
released where chadwick boseman is like
Black Panther has been a big part of the
Marvel Universe for the entire time
whether or not you realized it at the
end of Iron Man 2 we see Nick Fury and
Tony Stark talking I take a closer look
at the map behind them as a few
locations highlighted including Wakanda
this location off the shore here in the
Atlantic Ocean is actually an Atlantean
outpost that Namor had the actual
location of Atlantis is way up here we
haven't really got to name more stuff
but that gets into a black panther
sequels so we can talk about that in
other videos but even though Marvel's
had some creative problems with its
comics lately there was a recent run of
the Avengers where an adult version of
Peter Parker had sort of taken over the
Iron Man role and was running the
Avengers using his Parker industries
company which is sort of like
spider-man's version of Stark Industries
the thing about that though obviously
even if he becomes the actual heir
apparent to Iron Man you have black
panther who is even wealthier in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe so there's
just a couple key things that you need
to make an Avengers movie you need to
have your character who's written to be
a leader who can inspire people and you
need somebody to provide the funding it
costs a lot of money to be the Avengers
so Black Panther at this point you know
before spider-man grows up a little bit
more just encompasses all of those roles
but let's take a look at some of the
other Avengers so going into phase four
some of these are confirmed some of
these are maybes because they're on my
death predictions list and then there's
some that probably won't come into play
because the guardians will always be in
outer space so even though
technically they're gonna be Avengers
during the next two Avengers films
I don't really count them as core
Avengers because those are really the
people that stay on earth they do
earth-based stories they just crossover
with the cosmic universe every once in a
while so going into phase four you have
black panther potentially Sheree to
become an Avenger she's gonna be around
she'll be in the movies but I don't know
if they're gonna canonize her as an
Avenger right away spider-man Captain
Marvel Doctor Strange Falcon black widow
Winter Soldier
maybe Hawkeye the Hulk because they're
not gonna kill the Hulk off for good
even if he goes away for a little while
in Thor because Chris Hemsworth said
that he was totally gamed to come back
so he's gonna reassign a contract even
if he's not gonna appear quite as much
contracts coming to an end we've just
finished the last two Avengers and who
knows what what the future holds you
know we had felt like we kind of
reinvented that last one in a big way
and felt refreshed and re-energized so
we might have conversations if there's a
you know another great script that comes
along the maybes are Iron Man Captain
America vision Scarlet Witch in war
machine just from a contract standpoint
that I think some of them will stick
around but they'll take more background
roles like even if Robert Downey jr.
sacrifices himself during both Avengers
films they will find a way for him to
stick around we've given the example of
him becoming an AI version of himself
but I do think the events of the movies
will be so significant that he will just
kind of peace out and go on permanent
vacation without completely leaving the
Marvel Cinematic Universe
like okay this has been so significant
for my character I need to take a
background role like whatever reason
that you can invent in your mind for
somebody else to need to take the mantle
of the leader of Avengers on a
day-to-day basis we all make jokes about
how Disney and Marvel have problems
killing characters off I have a feeling
that that will continue to be an issue
in the next two Avengers films even
though they will find ways to kill off
characters it's just you have to
remember that most of these bigger a
list characters are billion-dollar
franchises for Marvel so if you think
that they're gonna kill them off and
never use those characters again they're
just silly
Disney loves making money they will find
ways of keeping the Captain America
character around even if somebody
takes the mantle war machine Scarlet
Witch vision those are not
billion-dollar franchises you could
actually find ways to kill those
characters off even though I hope that
they keep vision around just because
there's so much potential for that
character and he's so powerful but as of
right now they have not officially
greenlit Black Panther 2 even though I
think we're all confident that it made
so much money opening weekend that
they're gonna announce Black Panther 2
sometime in the next month or two before
we get to infinity war it's official
release they've already confirmed this
spider-man 2 will be the very first
movie to take place after Avengers 4
like it literally picks up in the
moments after Avengers 4 the way the
spider-man homecoming picks up right
after the events of Civil War they've
already confirmed guardians 3 which
takes place sometime after that the
Black Widow movie was just confirmed by
Chris Evans but we don't have a date for
that yet but the way that they do movies
now isn't they cross them over like two
heroes is better than one so everybody
gets their sequels but they just look a
little bit different it looks more like
spider-man Home Coming where you have
some Iron Man in it you use two of those
heroes to market the movie regardless of
how much that other big Avengers
character shows up during it there been
a lot of talk about spider-man crossing
over with a black panther movie
obviously that gets into a black panther
sequel spider-man sequels there's a lot
of reasons why they could do that like
Kraven was gonna be one of the villains
of Black Panther until Marvel was like
you know what no let's save him for
something else so what I'll do in the
next couple of days is we do more
Avengers Black Panther videos is I will
do a black panther sequel and just talk
about some of the key stories that they
could pull from when they do that there
is a new round of that Infinity Gauntlet
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video congratulations to
the winner from my last big Captain
Marvel video Joel G please private
message me so I can get your contact
details I've got new Jessica Jones
footage to post so I'll name the winner
when I post that video later today so
click here to learn about the Captain
Marvel connection during the Black
Panther movie and click here for all my
black panther easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]